[Applaudissements]
mais je vous explique en fait comment ça
se passe et qu'il ya toutes les notes
les deux très mauvais voilà les deux
plus mauvais choix curie de plus
mauvaise note et sont soumis aux votes
du public ça bah voilà donc c'est ça ou
pas non le soir où je suis sans voix je
regarde pas tf1 arte mission en tout cas
quoi qu'il en soit je voulais dire c'est
une émission extraordinaire à faire
vraiment j'ai pris énormément de plaisir
et je sais que c'est à dire j'ai pris
énormément d'argent j'ai entendu dire
que sur ce plateau y en a certains qui
voulaient la faire
oui mon pote tu peux la faire fonce
alphonse pas eu le choix j'ai pour
regretter de ne pas l'avoir fait
non non non franchement le jeu provoque
non vraiment rare était incapable je
n'ai pas le niveau j'ai peur des
blessures trop de boulot d'incapables
rennes vraiment vraiment bravo à ceux
qui la font oui on a perdu olivier minne
on a perdu kamel on a perdu sylvie
tellier qui on va perdre ce soir moi je
suis vraiment je suis pas bien quoi joe
bout du rouleau oui juste terrible parce
que l'on s'acharne c'est vrai un peu sur
julien lepers mais moi je trouve que
c'est pas celui qui c'est pas lui qui
dans ce mois maires intéressés qui ont
moi c'est qui ces quelques données revêt
d'ailleurs il est très fort il a raison
il s'énerve et qu'on doit aussi à juste
titre parce que bon bah ils ont vent l'a
fait vraiment un jugement de valeur
l'arabe à risque a pas d'humour sur lui
même face aux sabres de la page qu'ils
ont fait j'adore artus en plus mais là
c'est un peu la rage
en fait ils ont dit ils ont consacré un
dossier aux participants et ils ont dit
voilà rtu score tartus ne gagnerait pas
voilà c'était plus de la vanne et artus
y est voilà ils aillent là il a mal pris
parce que je crois qui la font dans la
coupe est aussi mais tous avaient perdu
ses parents avec fred astaire puis après
ils ont dit non j'déconne
voilà c'était ces deux-là vans années
passées à tes nerfs contre le site n'a
pas fini